with almost 500 sessions at next 2019
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't catch
develop deploy and debug using Google
cloud developer tools then stay tuned
because here's the rewind cloud
computing platforms are built on some of
the most exciting sophisticated
technology in the world but what makes
the cloud truly valuable is the amazing
software that you build and run on it
let's take a look at how Google cloud
platform helps you develop deploy and
debug in the cloud GCP leverages
Google's deep expertise in building
world-class software to bring you an
amazing development environment as a
developer you need actionable insights
throughout the entire software lifecycle
and tools to integrate from each phase
to the next so you can continuously
iterate and improve on your applications
let's start with the code Google's cloud
source repositories is enterprise-grade
get hosting for private repos its
architected to scale up to massive code
bases and provides extremely high
availability and it provides security
intelligence to prevent sensitive data
like access keys from ever landing in
your repo csr also comes with code
search you can search across multiple
repos at once using advanced syntax like
regular expressions code search is built
on the same technology as Google's
famous search engine so it truly
understands code entities like classes
functions and fields are indexed and
displayed as real time suggestions for
fast navigation next deploying
applications cloud source repositories
is pre integrated with cloud build
Google clouds fully manage CI CD
platform use cloud build to compile test
package and deploy your code to any
Google Cloud runtime including compute
engine kubernetes Engine and cloud run
but maybe not everything should get
deployed how can you be sure that what
you're running is safe Google's got your
back with services that actively detect
software vulnerabilities in every
artifact you store in your private
container registry when you pair
vulnerability scanning with binary
authorization for kubernetes engine
you'll have a powerful gatekeeper
protecting your infrastructure only
artifacts that have been given a clean
bill of health will have permission to
run on your cluster finally debugging a
running system
cloud source repositories works with
stackdriver to unlock your developer
superpowers are you trying to wrangle a
hard to reproduce bug with the
stackdriver debugger you can attach
breakpoints at specific points in your
code or capture a complete snapshot of
application state to find that needle in
the haystack amazingly all of this
happens without any need to revise or
redeploy your code and with no
appreciable performance impact use these
diagnostic tools on the fly in real time
for production workloads this was just a
taste of the powerful developer
experience on Google cloud platform if
you'd like to see the full talk check
out the link in the description below
and don't forget to subscribe to the
cloud youtube channel for more great
next rewind content thanks for watching
[Music]